Heat. Heat.
>> [music]
[music]
>> I'll just quickly run through the
schedule for the day. I request all the
brothers to have a look.
Alhamdulillah
the international dhawa training program
conceived developed conducted by Dr.
Zakir the second day of this 45 days
course Sunday 17th of January 2016
Mumbai India the theme for the day is
introduction to dawa.
Alhamdulillah today we were on time or
before time.
Alhamdulillah we were before time today.
Mashallah we are 5 minutes early. So,
alhamdulillah, I pray to Allah that this
good trend continues for the rest of the
days, inshallah.
So, the first session 8:00 to 8:20, we
just had the recap of the first day of
the international dawa training program
for 20 minutes. 8:20 a.m. to 8:25 a.m.
I'm reading out the schedule for you for
5 minutes. From 8:25 a.m., Dr. Zakir and
I would come on the stage inshallah and
we will have a very important and very
interesting session on material to be
referred for knowledge of Islam and this
session is going to be for 1 hour 50
minutes until we go for the tea break
10:15 a.m. to 10:45 a.m. we have the
first tea break then after the tea break
of 30 minutes the second session 10:45
a.m. to 11:45 a.m. again Dr. Zakinak
would give us his inputs on meaning and
forms of dawa. Meaning and forms of dawa
which is for 1 hour. It's a 1-hour
session followed immediately by a half
an hour a 30 minute session for the
question and answer. So if you have any
questions to ask on the topic meaning
and forms of dawa then you can keep it
for that half an hour inshallah. Then
from 12:15 p.m. to 12:45 p.m. there is
the talk on the topic characteristics of
adai which was told to you yesterday
followed by a question and answer
session and inshallah I would be taking
that lecture inshallah a 30 minutes
lecture with 15 minutes question answer
session then we break for our zur salah
at 1:00 p.m. for 15 minutes. Then 1:15
to 2:15 we have the lunch break as well
as time for you all to prepare for your
speech today. Your first prepared speech
of this international da training
program. I wish you all the best. May
Allah tab wa ta'ala help you to retain
whatever you have learned of the speech
and inshallah you should be lesser
nervous today because you have already
had the experience of this stage.
Inshallah
this 3minut prepared speech is the third
session for 2 hours which will be
monitored scrutinized and evaluated by
Dr. Zakir Nayak a 3minut prepared talk
by each participant. This will be for 2
hours and then we will break at 4:15
p.m. to 4:30 p.m. for the assar salah.
Then 4:30 p.m. to 5:00 p.m. we have the
tea break along with the reality TV show
inshallah which we will inshallah
discuss in the next time in the recap.
And we have in the fourth session 5:00
p.m. to 5:15 p.m. a 15-minute short
session on what are the techniques of
giving references from the Quran. Many
people think that you know how does Dr.
Zakir Nik come up with such references?
Is it a human brain or computer? So
inshallah you would know today in the
evening what is it all about. 5:15 p.m.
to 6:00 p.m. we have the cross-checking
of the names with meanings of only the
first 25 suras of the Quran which we
believe inshallah every one of you is
thoroughly prepared and inshallah let's
see who's going to be the best. And this
is going to be taken by Dr. Zakir Nay
for 45 minutes. And lastly, we have at 6
p.m. to 6:30 p.m. a revision of the
Quranic verses which translation helpful
for da'ah. So which translation clearly
suggests that you should also know the
Arabic part of it inshallah. So that
would be taken by me inshallah for 30
minutes and inshallah we hope to
conclude it on time 6:30 p.m. the
conclusion followed by salah.
Without wasting much time I would like
to invite Dr. Dr. Zak Naik to come on
the stage and start with the session on
material to be referred for the
knowledge of Islam. Dr. Zakir Nik.
Alhamdulillah.
I welcome all of you with Islamic
greetings.
To me, peace, mercy, and blessings of
Allah subhanaa tala be all of you. Now
we will be
doing a session material to be referred
for the knowledge of Islam.
And as I mentioned yesterday that
yesterday was just
talking about the rules and regulations
talking about the objectives
and due to
time limitation yesterday we could not
do one session that's introduction of
Islam which I did cover part of it in my
other sessions but if time permits today
we will at least spend half an hour on
it if not more inshallah.
As I mentioned that tomorrow or rather
day after tomorrow the third day of the
training program would be really the
beginning of the techniques as it's
mentioned in the schedule
and
they will come to know the technique the
structure etc. And though I mentioned
yesterday that this training program
would not be concentrating on the
knowledge of Islam, though
basic knowledge required
for basic level of dawa would be given
in this training program inshallah.
Today we'll be dealing on the other
aspects besides the hardcore technique
etc. And the first session deals with
material to be referred for the
knowledge of Islam.
At the beginning of the session, I would
like to make it very clear to all of you
that the books
that would be mentioned today,
all of them need not be authentic.
And when yesterday
come said that can we use the notes. So
then I thought okay fine then I have to
make a mention also.
So I would like you to mention in your
notes below which time did not permit me
today morning to revise it. mentioned NB
there on the notes itself on the bottom
of the page that all the books mentioned
need not be authentic NB
all the books mentioned in the list need
not be authentic
need not doesn't mean it is not
authentic
but
all need not be
The first and again this is a point form
note and while I'm speaking
I made it easy for you if I keep on
mentioning names and if you have to
write you will not be able to cope with
me. Therefore, I have given you easy.
Correct? So, I've tried to make the
workshop easy for you, not to make life
easy for you. So that I could squeeze
your effort in the techniques and the
other things rather than writing down
the notes.
The first section deals with English
translation of the glorious Quran. And
all of us know very well without doubt
the best source of knowledge.
The most authentic source of knowledge
in Islam
is
the word of Allah subhana wa tala. That
is the glorious Quran.
The first section deals with English
translations of the Quran. And you can
see it is mentioned at the bottom NB.
Since translations of the Quran is the
work of a human being, each and every
translation has mistakes. I don't know
of a single translation in the world
which does not have mistakes.
The only work which is infallible is the
work of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala.
However, the above translation have been
mentioned taking into consideration the
positive points and not the mistakes.
Let me be very clear
that translations
100% have mistakes but most of them have
more positive points than negative
points. Some of them even have more
negative than positive but the positive
points are so rare not available
anywhere else. So I've mentioned it
here.
Don't think that just because Ak has
given all these list that means this
list is 100% correct. Adai always has to
do research whether what he's speaking
is authentic is it correct and I'll be
dealing in more detail
doing the structure and content that
whenever you hear any matter from anyone
including myself it's best to check it
up. The reason of checking is that you
are reconfirming it's there.
Yes, anyone can make a mistake. If
there's a mistake, it is rectified. And
secondly, you yourself check from the
source. So you can delete one Ravi,
one narrator. Lesser the narrators,
the thing becomes more authentic.
Correct? Which we shall discuss if time
permits. So you have given a list of
translations and as I mentioned that all
translations are mistakes. But seeing
all the negative and positive factors
amongst all the translations each one
has its own preferences
and each translation will have its own
positive and negative points. The one
that I
personally
prefer amongst all the translations is
the holy Quran
text translation commentary by Abdullah
Alfali and
I'm aware that there are
many errors in it
and if you try and do a research you
will find many people who have pointed
out mistakes. Point number one,
anything which is famous or any
personality which is famous,
irrespective which field belongs to,
you will find that people try to take
out mistakes.
It may be right, it may be wrong. Why?
If you take out mistakes
in a very famous book or about a very
famous personality, they think okay they
get famous. That's one of the reasons.
Sometimes it may be that because he's
famous, we don't want wrong things to be
promoted.
So they start splitting hairs.
So many of times you find anything which
is very popular people try and
scrutinize it with a microscope and
every human being has got mistakes. So
if you look under the microscope there
is no human being who's free from error.
So because Abdullah is
the most popular amongst all the English
translations until recently in the past
1015 years
many and several new translations have
come out 15 years or maybe 20 years but
amongst
the early ones this I feel is the best
and maybe I got used to it so I'm
sticking to it
again I'm not saying that it is the best
English translation available for me.
Why? Because once a person gets used to
it, until you give me something which is
really multiple times more beneficial, I
may change. Because when a person reads,
he's used to reading a particular
pattern, he realizes that that this
matter is on the left side of the page,
this matter is on the bottom of the
page, it goes into your photographic
memory. So when I'm searching for
something, if I don't know, I know it is
there on this part. So if I change
unless
there is something really more
beneficial multiple times no I will
change. So so far I've not come across a
translation which is multiple times more
beneficial than Abduli for me as a D.
Seeing all the pros and cons yet I
personally prefer and recommend
Abdullahi because number one that it has
a variety of good things. Many tapas
or translations they are specialized in
one particular aspect
overall particular Abdul Sufali. Why?
Because
it is good to present to a non-Muslim.
Certain translations
are specifically meant only for Muslims
and we'll come to it later on when I
speak about it. This translation as a
whole with all its pros and negatives
I feel it is alhamdulillah
one of the best available
[music] muhammed
Allah
[music]
Fore! Foreign! Foreign!
>> [music]